pour l'anniversaire de l'armistice du 11
novembre parmi les très nombreux films
sur la guerre de 14 18
j'ai choisi un film qui est considéré
comme l'un des chefs-d'oeuvre du cinéma
mondial
il s'agit de la grande illusion de jean
renoir avec dans les rôles principaux
trois grands acteurs de l'époque jean
gabin qui pour l'anecdote a fortement
soutenu le film qui a eu beaucoup de
problèmes à se monter pierre freiner on
aristocrate erich von stroheim en
militaires allemands psychorigide qui
porte une minerve
aucun combat dans ce film sur la guerre
qui dénonce le nationalisme et
l'antisémitisme
c'est une histoire d'évasion ou sont
confrontés un ouvrier des militaires des
aristocrates un couturier fils de
banquier juif un acteur et un ingénieur
la grande illusion est un film d'hommes
il réunit des personnages d'origine et
de conditions très diverses mais c'est
aussi un film d'amour entre un soldat
français et une paysanne allemande dans
son chef-d'oeuvre jean renoir expose la
richesse d'hommes emprisonné par la
guerre et la condition humaine où les
affinités et les différences de classes
sociales ne résiste pas au besoin
intrinsèque d'amitié et de fraternité
le climat de ce film sans concession des
gages en permanence un réalisme puissant
est saisissant à la fin de la grande
illusion
jean gabin en parlant de la guerre dit
en espérant que ce sera la dernière et
marcel dalio lui répond mais tu te fais
des illusions le film sort en 1937 et
trois ans plus tard la deuxième guerre
mondiale éclate